pour être recyclés et valoriser les
déchets collectés sont triés préparé
dans cet immense bâtiment sur des
kilomètres de tapis roulant défilent à
vive allure et pêle mêle des briques
alimentaires des boîtes de conserve des
bidons des bouteilles en plastique ou
des métaux firme ici le recours à la
technologie permet de traiter un flux
important une trieuse optique prend en
compte la composition du déchet sa
taille et sa forme
enfin deux filières tous ces déchets
sont compresse ont d'énormes ballons
désormais ce sont des matières premières
recyclées parfois en raison de leurs
caractéristiques
certains déchets sont orientés vers un
tri complémentaires manuel l'objectif
est d'avoir un taux de qualité de
matière en sortit un proche de 100 %
afin d'être envoyées dans des filières
de reprise pour que ces matières soirée
employés dans les industries
complémentaires notamment l'industrie du
textile et l'industrie métallurgique
directeur de la gestion des déchets
depuis 13 ans à orléans métropole
thibault pain c'est aussi le monsieur
propre des finances il doit veiller à
l'équilibré des comptes
ce que ça nous rapporte directement
c'est de l'ordre de 10 millions d'euros
ça c'est ce qu'on va vendre on va vendre
l'énergie qu'on brûle à l'incinérateur
les déchets qu'on brûle produisent de
l'énergie on va vendre de la matière
première quand vous faites le tri dans
votre poubelle on revend les matières
premières tout ça sur le tri c'est plus
de 5 millions que ça nous rapporte plus
les énergies qu'on veut en plus les
professionnels qui paye un déchetterie
et ses environs 10 millions d'euros de
recettes sur la compétence viennent
directement de ce qu'on fait des déchets
et ça coûte combien
et ça coûte plus de 30 millions 30
millions d'euros donc la différence
c'est ce qu'on va chercher au travers de
la fiscalité et de la taxe que payent
les habitants est ce que les comptes
sont équilibrés
oui sans augmentation de la fiscalité
depuis en gros une dizaine d'années 20
millions d'euros ont été investis ces
dernières années pour moderniser les
installations et pour réduire l'impact
des rejets polluants dont l'atmosphère
et n'empêche l'incinération des déchets
toujours considérés avec suspicion lui
tom l'unité de traitement des ordures
ménagères organise des journées portes
ouvertes pour sensibiliser le grand
public à cette problématique et pourquoi
pas tordre le cou aux préjugés qui ont
encore la vie dure et c'est la fin de
cette édition va revoir ensemble les
principales informations à la mi-journée
incendie à tour la nuit dernière à feu
s'est déclaré dans les caves d'un
immeuble 43 personnes ont dû être
évacuées par les sapeurs pompiers et
quatre personnes dont un enfant et était
hospitalisé par précaution
et puis les suites de l'accident de la
route mortel de véro dans le cher le
chauffeur roumain du poids lourds à
l'origine de l'accident lundi après midi
a été placé hier en détention provisoire
le chauffeur roulait trop vite dans une
zone de travaux n'auraient pas non plus
respecté les distances de sécurité
cet accident dramatique a coûté la vie à
un père de famille et le pronostic de sa
fille est également engagée voilà c'est
la fin de cette édition à suivre et
militera en guyenne et ce soir à 18h58
vous retrouver rebecca denver avec très
bonne journée à tous
[Musique]